[Music]
I'm Christopher hi and today we're gonna
talk about poke in the book can we use
in this school is based heavily on
cyclist sensei's worth of cocaine but is
definitely focused through my
interpretation of book can be a lot of
other historical sources and my own
research into fighting swords and how
that works first thing we're going to
talk about one of the most important
things to talk about is kamae so how do
I stand with the sword
yep toss away and then come into brain
here Chuck's gonna face you sitting in a
regular you don't get in mind this is
chewed on Kip you mine there's some
really important things you have to
understand about the stance what's
basically happening in the stance is
josh is putting most all of his body on
this side of the sword so most all of
Josh's over here the only things really
that should be on this side of the sword
are just a small bit of Josh's arm and
enhance now just really wanted to
exaggerate this week's end down a little
bit and you can see how by making a
slight extension out the only things on
this side of the sword are in the sum
and the tops of his fingers here now on
a regular japanese-style sword there be
a tsuba right here a hand guard that
would prevent these from getting hit so
they can give enough angle to protect
these hands right here is his thumb and
his fingers and so what this stance does
what I'm going to go back into regular
Kenny planet so what this stance that's
warm is means that as long as the
person's sword is on this side they
can't have an irregular fast attack for
him if their swords on this side he
would have to adapt now the two ways he
would adapt is you move his sword or
sorry the one way you were to get this
suit which is feed so its body switches
to the other position so this is yaku
ken come on it's because his other legs
board and you see now he's done that
blending process where the sword would
be on this side and his body's protected
on this side so I'm just saying wherever
the sword is at they can make a quick
action there
can't respond to so you always want your
sword on the opposite side or your body
on the opposite side of their sword in
the hunting so Josh never faced each
other here so front end in mind you can
see I'm blade in it so my body is mostly
hanging on this side of disorder and
Josh's sword is over there if you look
at jobs the same things happening for
him the majority of his body is over
here while his his sword are my swords
on this side so I mean I can't make a
quick action to get Josh I were in shock
his hands need to stand there if I were
to tie his hands Asuma would protect his
hand so I can't make a quick action in
order to discharge I would have to
physically move my sword over to this
side now if that happened one or two
things he can do
he's either move his sword back so if I
moved over here you can just follow me
over there or he can move his feet so if
I moved over here they could move his
feet now he moves his see the problem I
have is the majority of my body is now
on this side of the sword and his swords
over here with me so sometimes I tell
the kids in the kids class it's like a
dog in a fence this is the fence that
protects me from the dog right now the
dogs jumped over the fence so the dogs
over here and it's where I am I don't
want to be that way so if I shift my
body like this you can see now I popped
the underside of the event and I
protected myself the other thing I can
do from here is drop my sword underneath
no sword dropping dropping actually
faster the feet will be slower but the
feet give a more definitive position and
this is the blade gives a less
definitive position so right now I'm
switching my feet I are by finishing my
sword I'm in a really good position to
attack Josh and now he's on the
defensive he's the bat position thank
you John so the idea here when we have
come on is that we're blading our body
behind the sword so I want my body
protected over here and anything
dangerous on this half of the sword so
when you stand in Maya finish and that's
what you're doing
now a regular Ken come on like this I am
NOT I'm not being really picky because
there's no one in range to hit me right
now and they starts getting the range
I'm good
then out more and more so my body's more
protected behind the sword now Bianchi I
can finally have Josh them back in here
we have a couple other commands we're
gonna talk about so have regular cheat
on Katie's mind which means middle
position with the sword
if Josh switches his feet we have Jakub
chewed on kidney to mine and so that's
middle position with the opposite leg
forward so in this you ideally would
always like that a stance where if your
right hands forward right foots forward
and in Japanese so Roy's you have two
right hand for than the left hand back
so this positions a little odd for jobs
yeah with opposite of how it really
ideally should be because he's got his
left foot forward but you might be
forced into that fight in my
circumstance he would however always
like to be in regular shoe not Hindi
life now he could also have Joe Don Ken
come on and that's a high position with
the sword here no notice now John she
naturally switched his feet he put his
left foot forward and now because his
brought the sword up his left hand is
all supported so this is a natural
position for a Joe Don Kenny in life he
can switch his feet and he is Yahoo Joe
Don Kenneth my right so this is because
now he's twisting his body a little
opposite of normal so the natural
position for a Joe Don is actually like
this because his left hand is
predominately forward so his left leg is
also predominantly forward
Chuck can also be in the gate on up
image might like that so I get on Kenny
- when just his right foot is forward
and it's Brett hands for it you see this
is a very natural position so these are
the different positions we're gonna
basically get in all the time shoes on
can utilize our primary sword stance and
that can be either regular or jockey
yup who's not ideal but you get forced
into them well step ja da which is a
high position like this this position is
built for striking immediately right so
I'm gonna go immediately into strike
from this decision okay we also have day
Don
Ken come on so right here nice low
position with the sword and he's set in
a nice low position so those are the
basic think John those are the basic
combine that we're gonna use for our
sword practice and understand
that is leading ourselves behind the
sort so we can use the sword of the
shield and Japanese swordsmanship we
don't have a shield like you would in a
European style we have a shield in one
arm that you can move around so our
sword axes both our weapon and our
defense basic to my four book in
practice